bienvenidos ahora resolveremos un
problema de movimiento de proyectiles un
poquito más difícil comenzaremos
dibujando al suelo y voy a dejar
bastante
espacio Este es el suelo y digamos que
lanzo algo con una onda
eh en un ángulo de 30
gr Aquí está el movimiento de lo que de
lo que lanzo en un ángulo de 30
gr y Eh quiero darle a algo que se
encuentra a una distancia de 100
m recordando que estoy en la tierra y
que me afecta la gravedad Quiero saber
cuál es la velocidad inicial a la que
debo lanzar este objeto o este proyectil
en la dirección de 30 gr para poder
darle a mi objetivo Exactamente Bueno
veamos Cómo podemos resolverlo aunque no
conozco mi velocidad inicial vamos a
suponer que si la conozco y voy a
descomponerla en sus componentes
vertical y
horizontal entonces Bueno aquí lo voy a
dibujar un poco
aparte tengo
mi
velocidad inicial o mi vector lo lanzo a
30 gr y de aquí voy a tener mi
componente
horizontal y en otro color vamos a
trabajar la componente vertical más o
menos
así todo lo que sea con respecto a
componente vertical lo voy a dibujar en
este color
moradito entonces Bueno vamos a
trabajarlo como si fueran ejes
coordenados nuestro eje horizontal va a
ser el eje de las x y el vertical va a
ser el de las
Yes bueno aprendimos en el video
anterior que usando funciones
trigonométricas
Sabemos que esta velocidad en el eje
y eh Y si la dividimos o usando la
función trigonométrica
si usamos el cateto opuesto
eh entre la hipotenusa que en este caso
es
mi velocidad
inicial vamos a tener que estas dos
entre velocidad inicial van a ser igual
a el seno de nuestro ángulo que en este
caso es de 30
gr si
despejamos nuestra velocidad en el
componente y o en el eje y Tendremos que
by y será igual a bi por el seno de
Cuál es el seno de 30 gr bueno pueden
usar una tabla o la calculadora pero con
suerte recordarán que el seno de 30 gr
es 1/2 así que nuestra velocidad en y es
igual a la mitad de nuestra velocidad
inicial bueno para calcular mi velocidad
horizontal regresamos a este
color tenemos que nuestro velocidad en x
es igual
al nuestra velocidad
inicial por el coseno de 30
gr porque ahora estoy usando mi cateto
adyacente y mi hipotenusa
y nuestro coseno de 30 gr es igual esta
es una x nuestra velocidad en el eje x
eh es igual a laelo idad inicial por el
coseno de 30 gr que es
ra3 entre
2 Bueno cómo encontramos la distancia
eh suponiendo que no sabemos este dato
que son de los 100 m Qué tan lejos
llegará nuestro proyectil bueno primero
tenemos que encontrar cuánto tiempo
estuvo en el aire después usando la
velocidad eh horizontal encontraremos la
distancia recorrida cuánto tiempo se
quedó esta cosa en el aire bueno para
esto vamos a usar nuestro componente
vertical
y y tenemos que en la diferencia en
distancia Perdón perdón me equivoqué
nuestra diferencia en
velocidad va a ser igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo recordamos que
estamos en la tierra y la aceleración es
la gravedad hacia abajo
nuestra velocidad promedio comenzamos
con nuestra velocidad inicial que es bi
y nuestra velocidad final es cero Porque
llegamos al punto máximo de altura en el
que se detiene antes de comenzar a bajar
entonces nuestra velocidad promedio es
igual a menos nuestra velocidad
inicial que la velocidad inicial la
encontramos o la acabamos de calcular
que es menos 1 Med de nuestra velocidad
inicial Esta es nuestra velocidad en
y que es igual a la aceleración de la
gravedad que es -10 m sobre segundo al
cuadrado por el tiempo y el tiempo que
nos interesa saber lo despejamos y nos
queda esto voy a aclararlo es 1 medio el
tiempo es igual
a si despejo esto hacia el lado
contrario me va a quedar a
un ve de mi velocidad inicial o lo que
es lo mismo velocidad inicial entre
20 bueno Esto es solo el tiempo que se
tarda de que lo lanzamos hasta llegar a
mi
eh altura máxima antes de desacelerar y
vamos a dibujar la dirección del
proyectil vamos a usar un bonito color
rojito entonces bueno yo estoy lanzando
algo con esta dirección de 30 gr y va a
subir va a llegar a un punto una altura
máxima y después de ahí se va a
desacelerar o va a
bajar hasta dar contra el
suelo entonces bueno Esto que calculé es
el tiempo en el que inició la
trayectoria hasta que
llegó a este punto si yo quiero saber el
tiempo completo que estuvo en el
aire vamos a manejar que es el tiempo
que estuvo en el aire y a esta t para
diferenciarla voy a
usar esta varb H para determinar esta
altura entonces Esta es t
h nuestro tiempo Total que estuvo en el
aire es igual a dos veces el tiempo que
estuvo o que le llevó llegar a esta
altura y volver a bajar Entonces es
igual a lo que acabamos de encontrar dos
veces por la velocidad inicial entre
20 y nos queda con que es la velocidad
inicial Entre
10 el tiempo que esta cosa está en el
aire estará en función de su velocidad
inicial en esta dirección de 30 gr Bueno
ahora nos quedará encontrar Qué tan
lejos viajó esta cosa pero esto lo vamos
a continuar de resol ver en el siguiente
video